i want you guys to watch this video if
you haven't seen it i'm not going to dig
it up in the card and put in links or
anything like that but
three years ago i did a video with this
little guy you can see what it looks
like here in the thumb
on how to take ownership a few months
later he got in an accident he died now
he wasn't supposed to live this long he
was only supposed to live to about his
um
first birthday if he was lucky is what
they said he had some kind of
degenerative bone disease so i'm pulling
this up here this is another public uh
facebook post and we've got uh mindy
who's his ex-wife she was married to him
at the time and they're there they are
together right so you get an idea of you
know what he looks like what his size
was and sort of thing
she married this guy and she's still
basically alpha widowed by him i saw
something here when i was scrolling down
um you know facebook does like on this
day six years ago a reminder blah blah
blah there's a post here from him to her
and you know she's still kind of alpha
widow by the guy you get the idea um now
is that a little bit of an extreme you
know example sure but a lot of the time
a lot of you guys take extreme positions
like oh i can't make the money because
there isn't enough money out there or i
can't get a girl because my insert
whatever reason
these are all losers mindsets and if you
want to adopt a loser's mindset and
focus on that then that's all that
you're gonna get you know if if you're a
hammer then all you're ever going to
look for is is nails everything's going
to look like a nail to you right so you
see a girl you're just going to be like
ah it's not going to work because of
this or i'm not this or i'm not that or
whatever it is or if it comes to money i
can't make money because of whatever
insert reason right everything looks the
same to you it just looks like failure
because your mindset's programmed that
way mindset's one of the biggest things
that a lot of guys overlook
it's so important and it's just it just
it just boggles the mind like you know
the title of this video is why 33 of
young guys aren't getting any results of
the women essentially
and look i hey i remember i remember
being you know 17 18 years old um i
think it was probably last year of high
school
and the teacher put out a uh a survey
this was in uh um co-ed gym class it was
a sex ed class i think he put out a
survey and he was asking the students in
the classroom um what their experience
was like and whether or not they were
virgins
and there's a lot of anxiety with a lot
of people in the classroom you know
about about you know well do i lie do i
tell the truth um you know what are the
survey results going to look like how's
that going to reflect on me
and dude it's it's you know it was like
i don't know if if stressful is the
world or or if
being anxious about it is probably the
best way to describe it but a lot of
guys
at that time were also involuntarily
celibate
now
at 30
that's a little bit too far at 40
definitely too far at 20 not a big deal
you know 25
okay you should be you know figuring
things out by then right because you're
an adult i mean you're not you're not a
child anymore i mean like even at 19
you're not really a child anymore if you
know what i'm saying but these are but
these are the skills that you have to
learn as a guy
and nobody's going to hand this to you
like no woman is just going to throw
herself at you unless you look like chad
thundercock no woman is going to be
throwing herself at you
in a way where you got to like beat him
off with a stick like you know there's a
get off me sort of thing you know it
doesn't go down that way it just doesn't
work that way
you have to figure out what women are
going to respond to that's what game is
i mean that's all that game really is is
figuring out what women respond to you
know having frame in that dynamic all
that really means is making sure that
you're leading and that she's
complimenting your life and that you're
not distracted with some you know
feminine bs that's that's making you
simp
and simping oh my god
do you guys want to spend some time
talking about that because the amount of
simping that goes on and
i don't even go looking for it it's just
like people are dming me crap and
emailing me crap
all day long and it's like all i see is
dudes doing the dumbest things and they
wonder why they don't get any results
with women i mean there's listen i get
there's guys that watch this stuff or
they've read my book and they're like
okay i get it i got to do some work but
even that guy said yeah i read your book
and there's a a section in my book that
talks about being significant being
socially significant and yet we click
the instagram and it's zero posts
insignificant right off the bat
right
most guys out there have to do the work
when i say most guys i'm talking like
probably 99 98 percent of dudes out
there need to do the work
and then that number then changes to
about
20 percent of those guys are
the ones that are being successful with
women
because they've leveled up and they've
done the work the one or two percent
that are just natural chads just have it
off the get-go they don't have to do
anything they just have to they just
have to exhale
they just have to walk in a room and
just be like
there's like three chicks looking at him
right away right
so most guys have to do the work you
know they have to figure out what women
respond to they have to figure out what
socially significant looks like they
have to figure out what you know
developing a strong masculine frame
looks like you know getting that v tape
or the 1.62 golden ratio that i talked
about figuring out how to make money not
being socially awkward being calibrated
around women and you know the right type
of situation having a sense of style
having a look you know all of those
things most most of these guys again i'm
going to say it again most of the guys
out there had to figure that out they'd
do the work now maybe they learn from
dad maybe they learn from an older
brother maybe they learn from a cool
chat uncle maybe they did maybe they
didn't
maybe they got nothing maybe they're in
the same situation as you i know a lot
of dudes that were raised by single moms
that figured it out on their own
and
you know again you can you can resign
yourself to the victim mindset
you can you can sit back and just be
like this sucks genetic determinism
i ain't gonna go anywhere with life blah
blah blah blah blah and hang out with
all your dorky friends in your little
dark corner in a hole complaining about
why things suck and taking measurements
of your jaw lines and paying dudes to
measure your jaw lines and tell you
about significance of jawline
measurements and
man
do i do i really need to beat on this
one
you know do i
oh my hair's falling out i can't do it
66 two-thirds of men are losing their
hair by the time they're 40.
i started losing my hair in my 20s i had
no problem with the ladies none
okay
max out in other areas that you can
control have a hairstyle that works with
you know hair loss if that's a problem
for you if you're not making money
you're working a part-time job you're
only making 30 grand a year in in your
city you know the average is 90 000 for
your age range make more money be
significant
you know what i'm saying
be something make something out of
yourself
you know
nobody's gonna nobody's gonna make you
do it nobody's gonna make you you know
be that person right
sean says hey rich how confident are you
in pp party for 2020 ontario election
scale of one to ten
what's pp party because ford so far has
sold us out with the v passport ontario
i think he means people's party
um
very low because people don't vote for
freedom they vote for free stuff
so i'm not uh
i'm not hopeful um i might i might try
to get uh max bernier on for a plane to
win episode i tried to i tried to book
him before but it didn't it didn't pan
out because it was during the whole
election and there was a short time
frame but we'll see
um let me go up back here through the
comments and see what we got
uh moff says smash more in 2021 than any
year ever blaming covet is funny yeah
it's like you know okay you can't go out
for a drink you can't have a coffee hey
you know what
why don't i pick up some coffees and
i'll come over to your place or why
don't you pick up so a bottle of this or
that and come over to my place that's
how it like saying that kovid you know
created complications for is absurd
you know
it's like
do you think that they stopped banging
when the black plague happened 100 years
ago do you think they stopped banging
300 years ago when the purple plague was
out or whatever it was
dudes are being indoctrinated to behave
like girls that's like complaining and
whining and whinging about things is
definitely not masculine it's not a
masculine trait you know like the people
out there that are making videos
about why you're a loser
and they wonder why right
man up level up and enjoy abundance
gentlemen
hit the like button thank you
uh
what was that about ridiculous notch
counts during covet yeah
yeah it sure does maf doesn't it yeah
sid's vlog money status power do the
work gets resolved listen you know
um robert kiyosaki uh is basic basically
calling it money sex power
you know you can call it looks money
status game frame you know
social significance captivation
captivation the part
is not talked about very often by a lot
of people which is why i've been
mentioning a lot lately it's because you
really can't be boring you can't be
basic
you can't you can't get away with being
basic you know guys will complain that
it's a lot harder today
okay
maybe
but are you doing the work like is
taking a couple of decent photographs
like jaren does and put it on his social
media
signaling that he's got an interest in
life is that really that hard
is it or is it that you're not doing
anything that's interesting that's
worthy of you know making a post on
you can ask
just he'll he'll probably be on moff
show later on tonight on stereo right
you can ask him
um
dude it's always there's always some guy
like you know complaining like alpha
will 420 or some [ __ ] all right okay
alpha will 420.
yeah um that's the thing and that's the
point that i was making jaron is most
guys don't understand the significance
of
signaling an interesting life don't use
my instagram by the way as a
measurement tool for this i keep telling
you guys it's it's a [ __ ] posting
instagram it's a business page that's
what i use it for right if you want to
see how you use instagram for dating use
jiren's example that's what you want to
look at
uh yeah you're going to get some more
followers today but
do interesting things take pictures
yeah
i think we've cut up on pretty much most
of this stuff over here
uh hey rich thanks for all you do broke
up with baby mother now living my best
life good hey listen dudes i get emails
i was just reading one like an hour
before i started the show i get emails
all the time i have this guy he's like
68.
sends me his before pictures his after
pictures tells me what work he did in
the last six months what he got out of
reading my book and it's like you see a
drastic change in the before and after
and now he's getting the results that he
wants out of life
you know if you're not getting the
results you're doing something wrong
you're either going to find a way or
you're going to find an excuse as to why
you're not finding a way it's as simple
as that
you